be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
concepts characters and teams from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're going to be counting down the
top 5 moments when Batman murder people
now to be clear we won't be covering
battles to the death instead we'll be
talking about times when Batman just
flat-out murdered another human being so
starting off our list at number 5 is the
grinder and Detective Comics number 613
in 1990 Batman finds himself in the
midst of a war between two rival trash
companies after stealing one of the
trash trucks and heading to the
Freshfields landfill
Batman witnesses a young man named Mike
being assaulted after he tries to stop
the rival trash gang from killing his
father leaping in action Batman disarms
one of the men and then turns to kick
another man
Batman's kick causes the attacker to
fall into another henchman sending them
both into the back of a trash truck with
her with her ground up in the machinery
prompting Batman to look on in shock
simply saying my god so coming in at
number 4 on our list is the junkyard in
Batman number 425 in 1988 following the
infamous act of Jason Todd dropping a
man off a balcony we find Jim Gordon is
actually kidnapped by the victim's
father a man named Jose Gonzales in
order to lure Batman and Robin to a
junkyard to enact his revenge after the
arrival of Batman and the unexpected
appearance of Robin Jose Gonzales and
his accomplice engage in a battle with
Batman and Robin but during the conflict
Batman is able to climb a stack of trash
vehicles which he actually pushes on top
of Jose Gonzales killing him in the
process now following Batman's act of
murder he informs Jason Todd that this
is fallout from Jason Todd from Jason
Todd's previous act of murder teaching
him that every action has a reaction so
rounding out our list at number 3 is the
Green Dragon statue and Detective Comics
number 39 in 1940 Batman finds himself
in a mystery involving two missing
millionaires
Batman's investigations eventually lead
him to the location of the two men who
were being held for ransom by a group
called the Chinese hatchet men jumping
to the rescue Batman is able to make his
way
to a platform with a green dragon statue
which he pushes onto the hatchet men
killing them all in the process in
addition to this Batman chases down the
hatchet men laugh and the hatchet men
leader calls him a fatty and then
punches him in the face repeatedly
declaring that it's more fun in a
punching bag so coming in at number two
is the fiery crash in Batman number 15
in 1943 as part of a series of
propaganda comics Batman has shown a
world with the Japanese in the Germans
had succeeded in winning World War two
in an effort to do their part in turning
the tide Batman and Robin ambushed a car
transporting Germans and Japanese
soldiers and using a previously acquired
rifle with a bayonet and spouting a
series of racial slurs Batman throws the
rifle at the tires causing them to blow
out which sends a car crashing into a
pole killing everyone inside by causing
them to burn to death so coming out of
number 1 on our list is the mental
patient in Batman number 1 the villain
Hugo Strange orchestrates the escape of
inmates from an insane asylum using a
serum it speeds up their growth hormones
causing them to grow to 15 feet in
height Hugo Strange sends them on a
rampage of robberies in Gotham City
proper after his capture and eventual
escape Batman begins tracking the men as
they continue their rash of robberies
eventually locating one of the vehicles
and disabling it Batman lowers a rope
around the around the neck of one of the
men dragging him into the air and
hanging him to death from the batplane
declaring that he's probably better off
this way with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end and that will catch you guys
later
please